Thanksgiving is fast approaching and I
want to know well my waistband
influenced how much food I can shove in
my face this is Brendan Brendan agreed
to eat a Thanksgiving meal three days
this week how did you get a bigger lap
token
shut up each day he'll be wearing a
waistband with different tightness jeans
sweatpants and a dress will determine if
his waistband affects how much food he
can push down his throat and each meal
Brendan will have a cup of stuffing a
cup of mashed potatoes a can of
cranberries for bread rolls a whole
pumpkin pie and a pound of sliced deli
turkey meat because markets didn't have
full cooked turkeys at the time we shot
this at the end of the meal will
determine how much food he ate and at
the end of this experiment we'll know
with which waistband he was able to eat
the most food let's eat gobble gobble
[Music]
normally on Thanksgiving I go ham
well turkey I guess but I eat as much as
I I just gotta hang out walk from you
for a while all right
easily my favorite things Thanksgiving
food wise pumpkin pie and the cranberry
sauce I like the sweet stuff so a lot of
people are very divided on the cranberry
debate a lot people are grossed out by
the jellied time that's just can shaped
there are a few things I love more than
a good old can shape of jellied
cranberry sauce fairly food it's
delicious definitely feeling it doing
the bloat a little bit I still got more
room I'm not stopping yet I feel like my
comfort level would be higher if I were
wearing sweatpants right now because I
already feel that unforgiving waistband
of the jeans just cutting into my
rapidly expanding gut mmm that being
said I'm gonna eat some of the spot
pumpkin pie is my absolute favorite
thing about Thanksgiving
I also typically just like to eat the
filling and leave the crust it's not
weird at all
lots of people eat the filling and not
the crust this is a documented thing
there's millions of us I'm at that point
you have an every big meal where your
brains like you're done you're good and
you're like I'm fine you keep eating I
by any reasonable measure should stop
eating right now but I have no intention
to because it's delicious I'm barely
even enjoying this pie now but I can't
stop eating it I'm high on pie I don't
know you know it feels gross
I'm gonna call it actually I don't know
I feel like it did pretty well I
physically could fit a little bit more
food but I am woefully uncomfortable
already I am getting paid today to come
to work in sweatpants and eat a bunch of
Thanksgiving food I'm free from the
clutches of denim strategy today I'm
gonna try to mix it up a little bit
today I'm gonna hit the turkey a little
harder I might eat a roll I don't know I
don't get out of myself
I feel like sweatpants are like a
magical talisman that you put on and
then you can suddenly fit more food in
your body
luxury baby yeah I already at this point
having eaten quite a bit of food feel
exponentially more comfortable than I
did in the jeans
[Music]
I think I'm done I ate more food but I
feel more just kind of like ready for a
nap as opposed to miserable I am super
excited to see how dressed day goes so I
will see you tomorrow I've never worn a
dress before turns out they are
luxuriously comfortable I feel like this
is gonna blow the sweatpants and
definitely the jeans out of the water
but America we got to adopt more dresses
for dudes this is fantastic today no
strategy my only strategy is I'm gonna
eat all the food I can and see where
this dress takes me well it turns out
Thanksgiving food it's still delicious
I'm very thankful obviously for friends
and family and loved ones and all the
important stuff but this year I'm mostly
thankful for this dress mr. Bress i'ma
hit the bread early haven't hit the
bread this early in either of the other
meals why am i hitting it so early dress
compared to the last two days at this
point in the meal I feel way better than
I felt the other two the first two days
even yeah even in the sweatpants I still
felt that bloke coming in and that
tightness around the waist I don't feel
that at all right now I feel like I'm
meeting naked which would be another
cool thing to try this is seriously
fantastic I feel like I could accomplish
anything in this dress is this is this
what women feel like all the time
pies good but again it's not as good as
my mom's pumpkin pie shout-out to my mom
so today in the dress I was able to eat
all the mashed potatoes all the stuffing
half the turkey about 3/4 of the can of
cranberry sauce and probably bout a
little over a quarter of the pie I do
feel like I ate the most amount of food
in the dress and was still the most
comfortable out of the three outfits
after calculating our numbers and taking
Brendan's comfort level into
consideration the winner of the
waistband Thanksgiving experiment is the
dress Brendan how do these results
compare with your experience the dress
made a huge difference not just in how
much I was able to eat but also how
comfortable I was while eat it don't you
have it folks wear whatever the hell you
want to Thanksgiving you're just gonna
shove your face full of food regardless
but wear a dress def definitely weren't
a dress
[Music]